moi je suis dans ma chambre et moi dans
ma chambre je suis en bunker
il faut pas rentrer dans ma chambre les
gars je te dis
et donc il y a ce fou qui tape à ma
porte à quelle heure trois heures du
matin 3h du matin j'entends quelqu'un
qui tape à ma maman
je rigole je lui dis est-ce que tu as du
réseau toi
le réseau je fais non mais il est
sérieux je rigole pas est-ce que tu as
du réseau parce que moi j'ai plus de
réseau ça se trouve ils ont mis des
routeurs dans la résidence on va se
faire canarder comme des chiens et moi
j'ai qu'une tringle à rideaux il me dit
oui c'est bon j'ai du réseau j'ai mon
valeur bonne nuit j'ai mis un mec sur un
mirador
j'ai mis de la lumière partout je vous
jure que c'est vrai et vous avez pas
fait la police non
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'aime bien faire des ronds de la nuit
en slip c'est bon ou pas avec un sac